♪ ♪
AND YEAH.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, GALLUP
FOUND THAT AMERICANS ARE
EXPERIENCE ON THE MOST STRESS,
ANGER, AND WERE IN OVER A
DECADE.
IT IS SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER THAN
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD.
WHAT COULD BE THE CAUSE?
IF YOU ARE IN THE MEDIA
BUSINESS, YOU WOULD SAY "TRUMP!"
THEY WERE FAR MORE LIKELY TO
FEEL ABOUT THAN THOSE WHO
APPROVE OF HIM.
THAT NUGGET SPEAKS TO A LARGER
POSSIBLE CULPRIT.
COULD IT BE THE MEDIA ARE
PLAYING A ROLE TOO?
WE ARE LIVING IN THE MOST
PROSPEROUS ERA EVER.
HUGE DECLINES IN POVERTY, CRIME,
AND ALSO DEBT THAT IS DUE TO
WAR.
WE CANNOT WORRY ABOUT TRIGGERS
AND SAFE SPACES BECAUSE WE'VE
NEVER HAD AT THIS GO.
IT COULD BE WE ARE SPIRITUALLY
WEAK.
EVERYONE WANTS TO BE STRONG.
EMOTIONALLY, INTELLECTUALLY.
BUT WHEN YOU KEEP ASKING
YOURSELF WHAT'S THE POINT, EVEN
WHEN THINGS ARE GREAT, YOU'VE
GOT PROBLEMS.
BUT WE KNOW GOOD NEWS DOESN'T
SELL.
THE MEDIA IS IN THE BUSINESS TO
MAKE MONEY, SO THEY CONVINCE US
TO IGNORE WHAT WE SEE AND FOCUS
ON WHAT THEY FEEL.
UNFAIRNESS, ANGER, OUTRAGE,
PAIN.
TO THEM, CATASTROPHE IS KING AS
WE HURTLE SOME ENVIRONMENTAL,
SOCIAL, AND POLITICAL
ARMAGEDDON.
SOCIAL MEDIA SPREADS IT.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN CONCRETE
EVIDENCE AND CONTRARY
PSYCHOLOGICAL SPENT HAS NEVER
BEEN SO BAD.
AND IT'S MAKING A SALE.
SO THE NEXT TIME YOU'RE FEELING
REALLY BAD, ASK YOURSELF THIS.
IS IT COMING FROM INSIDE YOU OR
FROM THE DAMN AIRPORT TV?
IN LIFE, YOU CAN TURN OFF THINGS
THAT TRULY MAKE YOU SICK.
THE GOOD NEWS HERE, YOU CAN.
I HAVE A THEORY.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS OVER
THE WEEKEND.
>> Dana: IT WAS A DELIGHTFUL
EMAIL EXCHANGE.
>> Greg: AND THEN I STOPPED.
>> Dana: YOU DIDN'T EMAIL ME
BACK.
>> Greg: I KNOW.
I WAS DRUNK.
WE HAVE SO MUCH THE SPIRIT IT --
IF YOU LOOK IN PLACES LIKE ASIA,
WHERE IT IS DRAMATICALLY
REDUCED.
THEY ARE GRATEFUL THAT THEY
MOVED OUT OF IT.
>> Dana: WHAT YOU WORRY ABOUT,
YES, I THINK THAT HUMAN BEINGS
ARE NATURAL WORRIERS.
YOU HAVE ANXIETY BECAUSE THAT
WAS SURVIVAL OF THE FITTEST.
SO THERE IS AN ILLUSIONARY PART,
BUT I ALSO THINK THERE IS A
SPIRITUAL PART.
I WILL JUST BE TO THE BIBLE, AND
I'M SURE THIS IS TRUE AND OTHER
RELIGIONS AS WELL, BUT IN
CHRISTIANITY, WHAT DOES JESUS
SAY?
FEAR NOT.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY.
I GOT YOU.
IF YOU GROW UP AND NOT, AND YOU
CAN KIND OF REMEMBER IT AS AN
ADULT, YOU HAVE TO LEARN IT OVER
AND OVER AGAIN, WHICH IS WHY YOU
CONTINUE TO GO TO CHURCH AND ALL
THAT.
I DO THINK THERE IS SOME
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY INVOLVED
HERE.
THE MEDIA CAN EXACERBATE THINGS,
AND I WILL INCLUDE SOCIAL MEDIA
AND THAT.
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
AT THEIR PHONES, SAYING MY
VACATION SUCKS.
MY DOG IS NOT AS CUTE AS JASPER.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING TO BE SAID ABOUT
HAVING SOME SORT OF GROUNDING
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO TURN OVER
YOUR WORRY SO THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE TO -- SO THAT IT DOESN'T
CONSUME YOU.
>> Greg: JESSE, YOU MAY BE THE
LEAST STRESSFUL PERSON I KNOW.
>> Jesse: IT'S TRUE.
I GOT A PUPPY, AND I REALLY
HELPED ME OUT.
JUAN JUST GOT BACK FROM BILLY'S,
AND HE HAS BEEN MUCH MORE CHILL.
THIS COUNTRY SHOULD BE MUCH MORE
CHILL.
WEED IS LEGAL PRETTY MUCH
EVERYWHERE.
I WOULD AGREE PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING TO CHURCH, NOT GETTING
MARRIED AS MUCH.
EVERYONE IS AFRAID TO TOUCH EACH
OTHER NOW.
PHYSICAL CONTACT.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT ANYMORE.
AND THE MEDIA IS HYSTERIA OVER
GLOBAL WARMING, THE
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS AT EVERY
TURN.
THE SOCIAL MEDIA ASPECT, AND NO
ONE GOES OUTDOORS ANYMORE.
GO OUTSIDE.
WALK UNDER A WATERFALL OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SEE A RAINBOW.
DO SOME YOGA.
HAVE A DRINK, TAKE A GIRL OUT.
YOU'LL BE FINE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, I STILL
BELIEVE THERE IS A VAST
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT IS GOING
ON IN LIFE AND HOW THE MEDIA
PORTRAYS IT.
I THINK WE TEND TO EXAGGERATE
THE NEGATIVE BECAUSE THAT MEDIA
SO NEGATIVE.
THAT'S MY THEORY, AND I HAVE
PROOF.
>> Kennedy: THAT'S WHY YOU
NEED TO UNPLUG FROM THE EXTERNAL
WORLD THAT TELLS YOU ALL OF YOUR
PROBLEMS ARE OUTSIDE.
AND YOU SOUND LIKE A DAMN
HIPPIE, BUT I ACTUALLY AGREE
WITH YOU.
SO MUCH OF THIS HAS TO DO WITH
MINDFULNESS AND NOT BEING IN THE
MOMENT.
SOCIAL MEDIA -- THAT TAKES YOU
OUT OF THE MOMENT.
AND THEY DON'T EXPERIENCE THINGS
ANYMORE.
I WAS IN FRANCE WITH MY
DAUGHTERS, AND THEY COULDN'T USE
THEIR PHONES OR DEVICES BECAUSE
I TOLD HIM THAT IT COST $1,000
PER MINUTE.
NOT COMPLETELY HONEST, BUT WE
WENT DOWN, AND WE DID THINGS.
WE WALKED.
>> Dana: THEY WILL REMEMBER
ALL OF IT.
>> Kennedy: THE NICE THING IS
THAT ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS
REMEMBER TO GET BACK INTO THE
MOMENT, AND THERE YOU ARE.
>> Greg: OKAY, JESSE GOT UP
PUPPY.
KENNEDY WENT TO FRANCE.
WE NOW KNOW WHAT THE KEY TO
HAPPINESS IS.
>> Juan: WHAT I NOTICED IS
THAT MOST OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
UPSET ARE THEY YOUNG PEOPLE, AND
THEY ARE MOST APT INTO
SOCIAL MEDIA.
EVERYBODY COMMENTED ON IT -- MY
SENSE IS THAT YOU HAVE A HIGHER
PROPORTION OF PEOPLE WHO
DISAPPROVE OF TRUMP, TRUE.
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT THE RATE
OF CHANGE AND CONSUMING
INFORMATION IS SO GREAT.
WE HAVE MORE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE AT EVERY STAGE OF LIFE
NOW.
>> Greg: TOO MUCH.
>> Juan: GRANDKIDS, THEY
SHOULD NOT HAVE ANY
SOCIAL MEDIA.
IT SLOWS DOWN YOUR BRAIN
FUNCTION, BUT I THINK PEOPLE
BECOME ADDICTED TO YOU LOOKING
AT THE PHONE, TAPPING INTO
FACEBOOK OR WHATEVER.
SO MUCH NEWS IS KIND OF SAD AND
DEPRESSING ANYWAY.
PEOPLE GET UPSET AND THINK THE
WORLD IS COMING TO AN END.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.